[Music]
well I think when we look outside our
windows every day we see a world that is
basically stable and even if we hear a
lot about extreme weather see horrible
news of wildfires and droughts and heat
waves they kill people all around the
world we still reorient our emotional
expectations for what the world will be
like in our own lives and most of our
lives have not been yet all that
dramatically disturbed by climate change
but in decades ahead I think they will
be there's basically no life on earth I
think that will be untouched by the
force of climate in the decades ahead
and in most cases that means deformed
damage transformed I think most
scientists would say that the best case
scenario is 1.5 degrees Celsius of
warming but personally I think it'll be
practically impossible for us to stay
below two degrees without what's called
negative emissions technology which is
fanciful tech that has been tested and
is successful at a lab scale that needs
to be deployed at global scale to make
much of a difference the UN says that to
have any chance of staying below two
degrees we need massive use of this
technology which we don't even know
enough to trust so for me I orient my
best-case scenario at two degrees and
unfortunately that's a level of warming
that most scientists describe as the
threshold of catastrophe many island
nations of the world describe it as
genocide that's how vulnerable they are
to especially sea-level rise it to two
degrees but the impacts aren't just
affect wouldn't just affect the island
nations of the world many of the biggest
cities in South Asia and the Middle East
would be lethally hot in summer at two
degrees which could happen as soon as
2050 they see these are cities like
Calcutta 5 10 12 million people you
wouldn't be able to go outside or
certainly work outside without incurring
a lethal risk and that could happen
again just by 2050 which is one reason
why the UN expects that we could have
200 million climate refugees by that
same date 2050 200 million they think
it's possible that we get as many as 1
billion which is as many people as live
today in North and South America
combined I don't think that those
numbers are realistic I think they're
too high but even if we get 100 million
or 150 million climate refugees it's
important to remember that the Syrian
refugee crisis which totally
destabilized European politics led in
its way to
and has transformed our politics
globally through the way it's affected
Europe was the result of just 1 million
Syrian refugees coming to the continent
we're talking about a refugee crisis
that is almost certain to be a hundred
times as large and it comes at a time
when most nations of the world are
retreating from our commitments to one
another retreating from our
organizations and alliances we're
treating from the UN we're treating from
the EU and embracing xenophobia and an
atavism and nationalism
that's especially concerning when you
think about what's ahead because they're
going to be many more people in much
more desperate need than akka in the
decades ahead and if we don't welcome
them
we'll be committing real moral crimes
that from the vantage of today seem
unconscionable but which may become more
normal as we move forward into this new
transformed world when we talk about
worst-case scenarios there are a couple
of different factors at play one is what
humans do this is the most important
factor will we change course will we
continue to burn coal we continue to
produce fossil fuel emissions and the UN
says that the track were on now the
trajectory were on now is likely to take
us to about 4.3 degrees Celsius of
warming by the end of the century if we
don't change course 4.3 would degrees
would mean 600 trillion dollars in
global climate damages that's double all
the wealth that exists in the world
today it would mean parts of the world
could be hit by six climate driven
natural disasters at once it would mean
more than double all the war more than
double the warfare that we see today and
the impacts would be in our economic
activity it would be in flooding and the
refugee crisis there are so many impacts
that we have we have not really been
able to think clearly about because all
of us are so reluctant to consider these
horrifying outcomes but the fact that
they are horrifying should not make us
turn away it should make us focus on
them more intently we all have all of
these psychological reflexes that make
us reluctant to consider horrible
possibilities and for that reason it's
more important for us to take seriously
the science because we need to fight
against those impulses to do better
planning to take more aggressive action
than we would if we allowed ourselves to
slip back into complacency but there's
worse there are cases
that are worse than 4.3 degrees there
are what are called feedback loops in
the climate system that could
conceivably accelerate warming beyond
what human action does so there's what's
called the albedo effect which is a
little complicated to explain but
sunlight is reflected back into the
outer space by any surface that's white
that's why when you wear a white shirt
you're cooler than what if you wear a
black shirt in the Sun in the summer
with less Arctic ice there is the less
reflective white ice there is at the top
of the planet that means more sunlight
is being absorbed which means that more
warming would take place so as arctic
ice melts the planets ability to reflect
solar energy back into space would
diminish and warming would accelerate
there is frozen in the Arctic permafrost
a lot of methane or a lot of should say
a lot of carbon which could be released
into the atmosphere as methane if that
permafrost melts methane is depending on
how you count at least 30 and perhaps 80
times as powerful a greenhouse gas as
carbon dioxide and there is enough
carbon in that permafrost to double the
concentration of carbon in the
atmosphere that we have today if that
were released it could accelerate
warming by a couple of degrees all on
its own there are many more feedback
loops like this just this past week
there was a study about cloud formation
if we get to about 1200 parts per
million of carbon which is much higher
than we are today at about 410 but it's
conceivable early next century we would
completely disrupt the planet system for
for cloud formation and that impact
alone scientists say in the study would
add 8 degrees Celsius of warming to the
system so we'd probably be at already
four and a half or five degrees by then
and we could immediately be brought to
twelve and a half or thirteen degrees
Celsius and that really would make much
of the planet literally uninhabitable
not just the equatorial band not just
the tropics but there'd be places in the
mid latitudes that would just be too hot
to live and we have not really begun to
think about those possibilities this is
the world that we're entering into now
just one point one degrees but the whole
range of possibilities stretches before
us and even the quite optimistic
outcomes are horrifying two degrees is
genocide the island nations of the
I'll say 4 degrees is at least twice as
bad depending on how you count and there
are possibilities north of 4 degrees
which are even scarier because it would
mean that a climate system had escaped
human control
[Music]